ANKUR KOTWAL: Welcome to part
two of the DevBytes series
Making Apps Beautiful.
In this part we're going to
focus on the spacing and the
typography of the list item, as
well as the detail view to
make it look more beautiful.
So let's just switch to our
phone to see where we were up
to at the end of
the last part.
And we've modernized the app and
had an action bar, gotten
rid of the virtual navigation
menu button,
the legacy menu button.
But we look at this, and the
text isn't particularly
well-formatted.
The images are an inconsistent
size.
When we go into the detailed
view, the text is going from
edge to edge.
There's still some glaring
problems from a design point
of view, and that's what
we're going to look at
fixing up in this part.
So let's go back to the slides,
and let's see what
we're going to try
and achieve.
The first thing we want to do
is have a consistent set of
heights for each of
our list items.
So we're using a 48dp rhythm,
as per the Android design
guidelines.
So if we look at where we are
now, this is actually what we
want to be.
So when we look at these slides
now, you see that the
list items are really nicely
spaced out, and we've got some
margins on either side of the
detailed view, as well.
So let's look at how
we do that in code.
So switching over to code,
we've specified a
dimension.xml file.
We want to abstract out the
values that we're using as
much as possible.
So we've got an 8dp vertical
margin, which just basically
means that on the text views
we're going to have an 8dp
margin above and below.
And so the way we're going
to do that is in
this list item article.
In our linear layout that
contains our text views we
have this margin top and margin
bottom defined with our
list item vertical margin.
In the detail view for the
fragment, we are also going to
use a margin left and a margin
right, and we're going to use
that detailed horizontal
margin.
And that's what's going to give
us the spacing on either
side of that detailed view.
So switching back to the slides,
and you can see the
spacing that we're after.
What we want to do is once we've
put those dimensions in,
we also want to now fix up the
spacing with the thumbnails.
And basically, what we want to
do here is eliminate that
inconsistency that we have from
thumbnail to thumbnail.
The way we're going to do that
is use the center crop
attribute on the image view
and set the scale type, so
that way it's nice and
consistent from
each image to image.
The next thing we want to do
is focus on the typography.
So if you look at the image
on the left, the
fonts, they're OK.
They're not particularly
attractive.
You can see very much on the
right-hand side that we've
paid a lot of attention to
detail there and made some
really good changes.
So let's look at what
we did there.
We're going to look at the
two main text views.
The top one is the title
and then the subtitle
in each list item.
So you'll see that we've used
a condensed font and made it
bold for the title.
For the subtitle, we've actually
changed the color of
the text so that it
contrasts less.
And you may want to abstract
that out, too.
And we've also made
it all caps.
The other thing you want to look
at is the fact that with
both of these we've actually
fixed the number of lines.
And we've used this property
called ellipse size, which
will basically truncate the text
and put dot dot dot if
it's going past that maximum
line specification.
So it's just presented in a
nice, consistent manner from
item to item.
So if we now look at the detail
page, the other thing
that we want to do is make the
author stand out a lot more.
And what we're going to do is
use this property called text
color link.
That text color link is actually
a property on the
text view, and we've just
used this bacon color.
Again, on the text views, all
you do is add that one
property and your links
will stand out.
But that also means that we need
to make that author at
that top subtitle
a link, as well.
So the way we're doing that is--
actually, for that part,
we're doing it programmatically
where on
create view we go and fetch
the font color.
And when we're going to put the
author in that text view,
we just put some HTML on either
side to specify the
font color.
The other thing that we'll see
that we're doing here is that
for the article body, as well,
where we're using a custom
font that we've shipped
with our APK.
So just getting to
our checkpoint.
If you see on the left-hand
side, that's where we started.
We've come a long way.
It's a really beautiful
app on phones, now.
So join me for the next part
for focusing on tablets.